[Music]
my name's Shawn gedevan I work on a team
here at Google called Android Enterprise
our team is responsible for the business
to business success of the Android
platform so if you're an IT organization
like an HSBC or a Walmart or a sa P
you're often interacting with folks on
our team who are working with partners
that help you deploy those devices to
help you build applications for those
devices John and myself work with large
enterprise is v's as well folks like
Salesforce SAT Manhattan associates
ServiceNow folks like that but we find
ourselves being brought into a lot of
conversations it feels like right now or
this interesting transition point where
IT is being asked to do more kind of
brand things and as an example we like
John and I were in a conversation with a
large retailer and they said hey we
really want to go and optimize our
consumer experience and I told them you
know well hey you should probably be
thinking about building for the web for
a lot of different reasons that we'll
talk about today and then they said
fantastic and then we'll use that for
all of our store associates whoa wait
wait not so fast let's talk about what
you want to do for this project what
that means for you know running mobile
devices in the warehouse and figure out
which technologies are gonna be
appropriate for you and that's that's
what we want to get out of today's
presentation so let's talk a little bit
about an overview of what we want to get
out of today's presentation what we
really are gonna talk about is an
overview of web technologies as they
apply specifically the Android will
touch a little bit about other mobile
platforms in the market as well well
also how to think about talk about how
to think about building APICS periences
so what are some of the design and
development considerations you want to
think about when building out web
experiences specifically for mobile and
we'll talk about some considerations on
trade-offs as you think about on a
project-by-project basis should I be
building for the web or building for
native
um this is not designed to be a deep
presentation about building for the web
it's not designed to be a presentation
on how to implement service workers
provide code level implementation for
PWA or for native we're not also going
to not cover things like grey areas
there's a lot of initiatives around how
do I make apps more discoverable how do
I make them surface and search things
like instant apps on Play we're not
going to talk about that as well because
I only have 50 minutes to get through
the content thank you for fixing the
clicker so we'll start kind of to frame
out this morning's presentation with a
little bit of a story how many of you
here in the room traveled from outside
of San Francisco and needed a hotel in
order to be able to attend next so most
of you about two-thirds so when you went
through that experience the likelihood
this is data from a talk McKinsey did
back in 2018 they looked at some data
around how people in the travel sector
were actually looking through their
purchase journeys and what they found
was that 63% of those journeys so from
hey I'm thinking about traveling to
Aruba to actually getting my plane
tickets purchased um came from a mix of
both mobile and cross-device journeys so
what that meant is I likely am on the
train on my phone going gosh it would be
really great to go to Aruba and then
maybe I go through and I do some
research I picked that that session up
on my desktop I do a little bit more
research I start to narrow down the
hotel's Google doesn't pay me enough so
the 5-star hotels get thrown out
immediately and I go back and forth
until I eventually go and make a
purchasing decision what they also found
was that 31% of those of those journeys
came to search so it's not that I went
directly to travel calm or whatever
website you choose Google flights as an
example or Google Maps to go buy a hotel
I went and used search to go through and
look for things like cheap flights to
rubra which hotels are best in Aruba and
I used that as a catalyst to starting my
purchase journey
26% of those purchases came from the
mobile web so that meant that somebody
in this sort of cross-device journey was
going through and finishing that actual
purchase on their phone and this is
really important because it means that
we really need to be optimizing our
experiences for a mix of different
devices we don't necessarily know from
the brand perspective which particular
modality a person's gonna be using when
they actually go and enter in enter into
my site and they'll that is also likely
true for employee apps we're seeing a
lot of employees use a mix of mobile
devices and laptops to actually get
their work done and so it's really
important as we think about what tools
will be enabling our employees with that
we'd be enabling for both now the web
has changed a lot web pages used to be
super static they used to load
everything at once and for whatever
reason back in the 90s I think mainly as
developers real like oh my gosh if I add
one more thing it'll be that much better
look there's a blink tag and I I figured
out how animations work so let's make
things scroll for inexplicable reasons
and sort of overloaded the sites this is
actually an example from Stack Overflow
that they did for April Fool's they
actually redesign the entire site circa
1990 so the good news is that at least
in the desktop web things have changed a
lot we're making sites much more
interactive you can actually now run
Windows 2000 in a browser I don't know
why you'd do that but it's a really
great example of webassembly the
challenge is that the mobile web has
traditionally been lackluster a lot of
brands many organizations use the mobile
web as a placeholder a static
placeholder to advertise the mobile app
they've built and basically there's a
link that says visit us on the app store
or visit us on Google Play or sometimes
they're not particularly good at this
game so they just say visit us on the
App Store and it makes really infuriates
us Android users and the challenge there
is that we know these patterns of
development behavior don't work the
Google+ team before we wound down
Google+ actually did an experiment and
they added an advertisement to the
Google+ app
to plus.google.com so when you went on
your mobile phone to plus.google.com you
saw this ad that's up here on the screen
that says get the app and what they
found in that survey was that 69% of
users abandoned the site entirely they
neither went to the mobile website nor
did they actually go through and
download the application say what you
will about Google+ is a platform I think
this is indicative of a broader user
behavior the activation energy to
download an application particularly as
a consumer who's not really attached to
your brand is high I have to go to play
I have to click install I have to wait
then I have to sign up for an account
and if I've never heard of your brand
before why am I gonna go through all of
that work and so it's really important I
believe to be thinking about at least
having much of my experience optimized
for the mobile web it doesn't
necessarily mean abandon your your
mobile application Spotify has actually
gone through this journey where they've
said hey we want to allow users to
discover music so if anybody has been to
bottle Rock Napa Valley or other music
festivals likely you gets a custom
Spotify playlist that says you know it's
designed to get you excited about the
band's you're gonna go see and it used
to be you click that link and it says hi
go download the Spotify app and if your
answer is what to Spotify you probably
just abandon that experience entirely
and so they've really seen a high degree
of conversion since opening Spotify up
to the web of people who are actually
finding about out about the service do
these other brand interactions like
music festivals like news articles and
the like so we know the building for the
mobile web is important so if we're
gonna build for a built better mobile
web what are some of the things that
we're absolutely want to want to
consider one is around making our web
experiences engaging that starts with UX
and really optimizing around the variety
of form factors and screens that the web
presents right not everything's a phone
not of things the tablet foldables are
gonna make this even more confusing
because it'll be both in my pocket and
so we really want to make sure that
we're making really dynamic UX
experience
we want to make our sites engaging
through things potentially like hardware
integrations we'll talk about hardware
in a minute
through push notifications so being able
to go through and re-engage our users
that come to our site hey I saw you
liked this pair of black slacks there's
a new there you know they're now 10% off
or we now have them back in stock which
happens to me and then credentials being
able to go through and actually if the
user has saved credentials being able to
reuse those credentials or even
potentially being able to single sign-on
through credential stores like Google
another consideration is making the web
installable so if I'm as a user have
visited your brand and I'm really
showing a high degree of engagement how
do I get them to come back now one
option may be hey go download my my my
mobile app it really seems like you like
me another way is just to say hey can
I'm gonna add this web experience to
your home screen and this experience
might not be everything that you want to
do for your mobile experience but you're
sort of bringing that user into the
experience transition them through hey
I'm gonna add this to the home screen
maybe with this even more engagement I
keep them there or maybe I bring them
onto my mobile app and so in addition
for those of you that are Enterprise
developers you can take web experiences
and surface them through manage Google
Play manage Google Play is a version of
the Play Store that's available for
enterprises who want to distribute
internal applications out to their
employees and so you can create
basically your own private Play Store
that distributes native apps and now you
can distribute web apps as well we want
to make sites reliable for all the talk
about 5g connectivity is not perfect I
read a stat recently that roughly half
of all of all connections on the web are
still coming from 3G devices or 3G
networks so we really need to be
thinking about performance optimization
which I guess Falls more in the fast
bucket but also hey I'm going from
London to Paris and I go through a
tunnel I get buck online and I go
through a tunnel again and I go back
online and I'm on a tunnel again this
happened to John and I recently because
we were both in France visiting
customers and I was not particularly
active on those websites that didn't
know how to optimize for offline and
then finally I'm fast so we really want
to make sure we're optimizing
performance we know that low bandwidth
high latency connections are still out
there and we want to make sure that
we're optimizing for those and we'll
talk about some of that in a minute
one way to enable these reliable
experiences is through service workers
so service if you think about the old
way of doing the web the old way is I
would basically have a server out there
somewhere on the internet my browser
would go and pop up and it would
download everything at once
that was fine but as sites became more
complex and more interactive it became
really really tricky to go through and
do everything at once and so the idea of
service workers is that you can build
out a client-side proxy in JavaScript
and have a little agent on the inside
the browser that's separate from the dom
and separate from the main thread that
can do work on your behalf some of that
work or things like notification api is
that we'll talk about in a minute
push api is which allow you to go in and
and get push messages to go and do other
things
background synchronization so you can go
through and start to go and paint the
page and load additional things in the
background as the user starts to figure
out where they want to go when we think
about the web though it's great to have
a bunch of technical tools that are at
our disposal but one thing that I often
coach people about is you really want to
build out your UX to be dynamic one way
to do that is to use a lot of the design
patterns that are already in material
you can use things like responsive grids
and breakpoints to change the UI as the
screen size changes i'm twitter with
twitter light has done an excellent job
of this where as you go and expand the
screen not only am i changing the
horizontal width of what's being
displayed but as I go from smartphone to
tablet and out to desktop I'm actually
uncovering additional functionality and
additional content because I now have
the additional screen real estate to do
so so you can see on the on the
right-hand side as the browser as the
browser pane goes and expands I actually
go Twitter actually goes into
hey here's who you should follow here's
trends in San Francisco in addition to
the the twitter feed for google next
nineteen these um design patterns are
not only relevant for the mobile web
these are also design patterns are
highly relevant for native apps as well
many of you are aware that Android
native apps can run on Chromebooks and
certainly Chromebooks if you're
designing for Chromebooks need to be
more responsive things like window
resizing maximizing and whatnot it's not
particularly awesome to be on your
Chromebook and go cool a phone app and
it just looks exactly like a phone app
and you want to be designing for it for
for both one final thing about the web
is you can also design those apps and
run those apps in full-screen so you can
actually have your applications your web
applications run almost as if they were
like a native app another way to think
about dynamic workflows is to hardware
integration so obviously cellular and
Wi-Fi those are gonna be your base
connectivity mechanisms that are
allowing you to go and get content into
the browser
but there's a lot of other hardware
capabilities that come with building out
for PWA things like GPS hey I want to go
through and find what store locations
are near me or where something is in the
mall I can pop up my location and
provide some interactivity back to the
user or potentially even things like the
camera for object recognition or
microphone for for voice search you have
a lot of these hardware capabilities at
your disposal whether you're building
for the web or building for native John
we'll talk about in a minute that this
is not obviously the totality of
hardware that's available on Android and
so you'll need to be thinking about the
level of hardware interactivity you have
when deciding which tools that you want
to build for your projects um push
notifications are a really great way to
actually engage with your users and
actually get them to re-engage with your
website um one of the pieces of guidance
I give is please don't go as soon as I
hit the site and say hi I'd like to
subscribe you to push notifications
because one that's obnoxious and two
it's not I have not really shown a ton
of brand loyalty to you yet like you
haven't necessarily earned the right
to go through and start sending me a
bunch of additional notifications but if
I miss and in that Lancome has actually
done this on their site shown a high
degree of interest on things I'm
actually navigating through the site I'm
engaging with a lot of different content
I can go and not only ask for push
notification but more importantly
emphasize what I'm gonna get from
subscribing to those push notifications
so as an example I can emphasize in the
case of Lancome that hey let me tell you
what some of the best deals are let me
tell you about new products we're gonna
bring out for the season and I'll bring
that content to you right away one of
the things about push notifications is
in Android when you subscribe to push
notifications Android will wake you up
in the background and actually surface
that push notification in desktop the
browser actually needs to be open the
browser needs to be resident in memory
for those Bush notifications to work so
there's some the reliability of those
push notifications may change depending
on whether or not you're designing on
desktop versus web credential management
also comes up quite a bit from customers
and the good news is that there's really
great api's for the web to handle things
like credential management so you can
actually go through and say hey surfaced
out to the user I know you're signing
and locally you're not clicking in sign
with Google you're actually using local
account credentials to acne Inc do you
want to save these credentials and
credential management allows you to save
those into the browser and in cases like
chrome you can actually save those
credentials across devices so I can hop
between my Android device my Chromebook
my Windows desktop why I would use that
I don't know but I can go through and
have those credentials be stored across
across devices not just across sessions
and you can decide whether or not you
want to store the entire set of
credentials so username and password or
just autofill username and have these or
type and password those decisions are up
to you um the next is to create an
installable experience Starbucks has
done this what they're Nate I would
start with their word native with their
web-based application for doing things
like checking in Starbucks rewards or
going through and ordering lattes from
the local Starbucks what the add to
homescreen prompt allows me to do is do
just that add that PWA experience to my
home screen that allows the webpage to
install much like a native app and with
things like an app menu in the apps
settings tray in Android
it adds obviously you know home screen
icons and the like but again you really
want to be triggering this prompt at a
meaningful moment for the user I don't
necessarily want to install the
Starbucks experience the first time I
start you know go to Starbucks calm I
might want to install the install the
Starbucks experience when I've
successfully ordered something or I'm
checking my account or at least I've
logged in and saved credentials because
the likelihood that I'll want to come
back to that is much higher I mentioned
manage Google Play there's also you can
also surface pwace for your brand into
Google Play itself so if you're entirely
on the web you can actually publish
these web experiences both for employees
as well as for the consumer Play Store
when you're distributing these
applications through manage Play you can
decide how both who you want these
applications to go to in your install
base so you can decide hey this is a
financial workflow app don't publish it
to the entire company only publish it
out to the people in finance and you
don't have to be a G suite customer to
do that there are tools out there where
you Confederate manage Google Play to
your existing Active Directory or other
LDAP data store so you don't have to go
and create G suite a G suite domain or
create gmail accounts for every user
inside of your organization and as you
go and create the app store listings for
your users you can decide how you want
that application to render do you want
to render like a website and so show
things like the toolbar and the address
bar do you want to be more of a minimal
experience so users can differentiate
when they're in a native app versus when
they're in the web or do you want to
just have it be a full screen experience
have it be a full screen experience and
feel much more like a native application
you can publish these applications out
via a few different mechanisms certainly
you could publish the play console but a
couple of new mechanisms we've recently
introduced are custom publishing api's
which allow you to basically script a
lot of application management to manage
play as well as the manage play iframes
so for those of you that have a mobility
management system you can now control
play directly from from your EMM who
here is seeing the screen before now I
love when I go offline because it means
I get to go and play the dinosaur game
and like figure out you know what what I
can whether or not I can beat my
high-score and from this animation I'm
not particularly good at it
but the point here is is that as much as
I might love this level of interactivity
it's not necessarily great for your
brand experience it's not gonna help me
continue to research hotels it's not
gonna help me figure out whether or not
I want to go purchase something so as
designers and developers we really want
to try and limit the amount of offline
messages that we give out to the end
user and potentially even have quite a
bit of work flow available even while
that user is offline so one thing you
can do and this is both a performance
benefit as well as an offline benefit is
cache certain parts of your site locally
into the browser that allows you to go
through and allows the user to have some
degree of interactivity and continue to
browse inside of your web app without
necessarily having to be online more
importantly you can go through and this
is this is super useful in workflow
based applications so imagine if you're
an airline
I don't need necessarily need to be
online to go get my boarding pass or to
go look up my trip itinerary or know
what gate I know I guess I gates change
but the idea here is is that I can
surface the last known information about
my flight without having to necessarily
be online that's super useful for
traveling internationally by the way but
certainly also you want to allow users
to continue to use the Site and alert
them when they're offline so pop open
say hey you're offline right now this is
an example from trivago you're offline
right now I'm gonna go and display what
I can and you can reconnect or maybe
used
to go and start a workflow cache in the
background and resume it when the user
comes back online but and we know that
in addition to offline support
performance is absolutely critical 53
this is a recent study from Accenture in
Google looking at users in asia-pacific
fifty-three percent of mobile visits
were likely to be abandoned if load
times were greater than three seconds
twenty percent of dropping conversions
were found for every second that a delay
of delay in a mobile web site so in
other words if you don't have really
fast sites people won't actually go
through your experience and they won't
buy stuff so we want to go through and
make sure that we use caching for speed
and reliability speed up the load time
for returning visitors ensuring a
consistent experience and also again lay
that foundation for offline experience
we also want to use things like lazy
loading and lazy loading allows you to
go through and start to render the first
parts of the page but also work in the
background to go through and load things
that don't necessarily need to be up
there and up in front of the user in
order for that first piece of
interactivity this is actually an
example from tinder where they were
going through and looking at how their
site was built and they found they were
loading a lot of images from places like
Facebook and other places and the user
hadn't logged in yet so what's the point
of reloading all the pre loading all
this content if the user hasn't logged
in and hasn't created a tinder account
so you can go through and say hey login
or create account and be in the
background loading all these images so
the user has a fast experience once
they've gotten through that first game
performance budgets are another way to
do this you can go through and set
milestones to make sure that technical
debt doesn't increase in your site and
you don't go and degrade the experience
as new features get implemented over
time just some milestones that you might
think about these are actually from web
dev and given the Accenture data I might
say three seconds instead of five for
time to interactive you can also look at
things like the size of the code that
you're having so you can optimize that
but there's the milestones that you
really should be thinking about our
first contentful paint which is
basically when data starts to be
displayed
into the browser and then time to
interactive how quickly are you loading
that site and in order for the user to
have a meaningful interaction be using
testing and validation tools we have
things like light lighthouse and webpage
calculate from Google that can help you
go through and optimize but don't just
optimize once this isn't like the
rotisserie oven where you set it and
forget it
you actually have to be doing this as
you go and re-release the site or you
can end up with performance degradation
x' i'm guys skip that slide because
that's not particularly useful slide so
let's talk about this from a case study
perspective PWA is a great they've
clearly offers a lot of benefit but what
does it look like from an end to end
experience so this is actually the
trivago app again just continuing with
continuing with our theme of travel and
you can see here when I go to trivago
I'm coming back as a user it says hey
would you want us to go and add this to
the homescreen so I can add trivago out
and come back to it I type in San
Francisco I start to get my wildly
overpriced hotels here in the city
because there's like next and two other
conferences going on right now
and all the sudden I've experienced the
connectivity disruption which you can
see you can see actually here in the
middle pane and so you can see even
though I'm excited here in the middle
pane so as I go through and I go through
that connectivity disruption I can still
go through and browse to the site look
at some amount of data that's been
cached in the background and then when I
reached that limit of what's been cached
onto the device I go through and get a
notification hey you're offline do you
want to you know reconnect and continue
browsing and obviously when I restore
the connection I can go out there and
buy my hotel trivago has also done a
really good job of optimizing their web
experience for native and mobile so you
can see that I'm getting a very similar
look and feel whether I'm using this on
my Android device or whether I'm using
this on my Chromebook so they've they
know and I think they understand this
idea of multi-modality interaction and
the fact that I'm likely gonna go to
trivago once look at some stuff go to
trivago again look at some stuff and the
devices that I do that with are gonna
vary so let's make sure there's a
consistent experience across them in in
the trivago case they've seen
exam a ton of benefit in migrating a lot
of their functionality to the web
they've so far launched across 33
languages in 55 countries but more
importantly they saw a 97 percent
increase and click out so tel offers
when they actually went and optimized
for the web experience so rather than
telling the user hey go download
something go through lots of additional
steps in order to get into trivago
they're actually saying people go
through a really elegant flow and the
users are then buying at the end of that
purchase by going offline they and while
the dataset is relatively small in the
case study they still saw a 60 to 70
percent improvement in return visits to
the site when there's been connectivity
disruptions so because they're providing
a really interactive experience even
when the users offline the users willing
to come back or persist through the
connectivity disruption in order to go
through and engage with that brand so
we're we're set right we're all in for
the web Jon's actually gonna go and talk
a little bit about some of the
challenges we've seen with customers
particularly as they think about
enterprise app workflows and why don't I
turn the stage over to you to talk about
native thank you hey thanks Sean so
before we get started here when Sean
first asked me to do this talk with him
the first thought in my mind was this is
a horrible idea the web versus native is
almost never goes well
there's always a Twitter or something
that comes up from it so apologize in
advance I'm gonna be as objective as
possible you know a lot of people ask my
advice and again that's why we're doing
this is because people ask us so often
you know what are we billed for and
obviously the decision to build for
mobile or web really depends on what
you're doing and I never just say oh
just because I work on Android you know
you should always build for Android or
you should always build for native so I
would never say that so just just want
to preamble the you know this section of
the talk so with that said my name is
John Markoff I lead developer relations
for Android enterprise and you know as
Sean mentioned you know the web has a
lot of benefits and a lot of great
things if you're building native apps
and especially enterprise space there's
a few other things you might want to
take into account so if your app is
going to store a lot of information
locally
web browsers especially in mobile have a
lot of you know more restrictions on how
much storage and data you can save
offline Chrome for example you can save
up to 6% of the free space on the device
whereas something like Safari you only
get 50 megabytes total so if your app is
for workers in a warehouse or delivering
packages or something like that where
you're not gonna have connectivity all
the time and you need to download a lot
of different things especially if you
are a service provider or you know
someone that a cable company fixing and
you need videos to be able to like
understand and like see different
situations where you're you just need to
have a lot of space in the device so if
you're downloading videos you don't like
a lot of local content for offline the
web might be a bit challenging there for
you especially if your device is lower
powered and doesn't really come a lot of
storage so if you could only have like 4
gigs of free space you're gonna have not
too much with even chrome in this case
so I Shawn mentioned you know the web
does give you a lot of available ated
hardware but there's a few things that
are different so for example NFC and
attestation are two really large ones
that are missing from the web you do
have the ability to use biometrics so
you can authenticate on the web but if
you want to do more Hardware backed
Keast Android key store or crypto you'll
need to have a native app to access
those features and again this is kind of
just an overview of all the different
web browsers and the features that they
support so let's talk about native app
security if you store files on the local
filesystem like who can access them you
know ideally only you know your user and
the person using the device but what
happens if the device is stolen what the
device is compromised in some way how do
you ensure that your data is actually
stored properly especially in offline
mode with the web you don't really have
any options of how to change this data
because unless you do some sort of like
JavaScript crypto which would would not
really be able to take advantage of the
DES trusted execution trusted execution
environment
on Android so hmm for data at rest so if
you want actually store files and you
want to encrypt them on the device you
can use the Android key store with the
native app to ensure that your keys are
never leaked and will never come off the
device your application cannot even get
the key material once it's created as of
Android or EO we added sensitive data
protection what this means is your key
you as a user you must be using a phone
that's been unlocked so the key won't be
available to the application if the
device isn't unlocked and to add to this
even more they they also support
biometric authentication so when you
creating keys with the enter a key store
you can actually set flags to say always
require authentication have a time-out
on the authentication and require
sensitive data protection so you could
actually have it require a user to be
present for any time the keys even
access so depending on the level of data
that you're working on here with key
attestation you can also ensure that
your keys haven't been compromised and
that they never left the device what
about data in transit what if I'm
sending data what if I'm calling really
sensitive services and I need to make
sure that someone hasn't injected a bad
certificate you can use OCSP which is
the online certificate status protocol
which is built into Android as a nougat
which is Android 7 and that allows you
to add checks to actually ensure that
you can talk to your certificate
authority and make sure that this
certificate is valid and it is what it
says it is one other thing you can do as
well is TLD verification so that's the
top-level domains and making sure that
someone hasn't created a fake one or
someone hasn't tried to compromise the
device protected conformation we
launched a Titan keys on pixel devices
and we just announced that we're taking
that to more devices as of yesterday
with cloud and on Android and protected
conformation allows you to verify that
the transaction you're trying to
accomplish is being executed by our
actual person on the device so similar
to a
be key if you want to login if you have
a corporate laptop it basically makes
sure that you are actually present so
someone's not emulating or stimulating
your application and in a you know
Android studio or other tools and it
provides the fact that you're there
because if someone packets sniffs your
services they can try to bake calls and
replay calls but with built-in hardware
in the device you can't fake that safety
net one other thing that you can't
enforce when you're building just a pure
web app on mobile is how do I know if my
device has been routed how I know how do
I know if I'm actually on a real Android
device at all because you know you can
rip apks from the web you can rip them
off your phone and try to run them you
can deconstruct them and figure out like
how can i how can i try to compromise
this app how can I try to replay and run
run this app without doing that safety
net allows you to validate that you are
actually on an actual device and it's a
CTS compliant device that means that
Google knows about it and it's a device
that meets the test specifications of
what we have so somebody just didn't
build a random open-source version of
Android just to try to compromise and
run your app as an example here's what
safety looks like after you call it I'm
not gonna jump into the code here but
just as an example like the two last
fields in this JSON signature blob that
come back our basic integrity which
means has this device been rooted at all
and CTS profile match which means that
it's actually a device and in more
detail safety net has a few steps that
it takes and this is to ensure that you
actually know that you've won you you
know that the call is happening you know
what user is using is actually calling
the service and then ensuring from
Google that I actually have a real
response from safety net so to jump
through these really quick the first
thing we're gonna do is you're gonna
generate a nonce which is a one-time use
token and that should be tied to
whatever user is logged in for your
application in that way and this is
something you save and make sure on your
back-end yourself that
you know is only used once and you know
it's tied to the correct person in
Android you would call safety net you
call the API to attest that this device
has not been routed in to reach out to
Google to say hey you know do you know
about this devices have been routed
what's going on here you're gonna get
back the JSON web signature that I
showed you earlier that has a key is a
signature and all the different fields
that you might want to look at time
stamps apk you know is this compromised
or not and you need to send this back to
your server and check all these fields
to make sure hey does this make sense
you know I just sent this it was a time
make sense does the signature make sense
and you reach out to Google to ask one
last time hey by the way yeah you know
did you just a real response does the
signature match if yes that's great
you're fine if not then you know that
you can disable that user on your
back-end as well so that means that you
know that this user has been using a
compromised device and you can block
them from accessing any any services
after that you know one other thing as
well that you know you have some device
management with Chrome and web browsers
on mobile but you have much more control
over this with third-party tools like
MMS which allow you to inject settings
into your application so if you're
building for the web you would have to
build in all the different features so
if I wanted to have a configurable
application where I have different
settings based on different user types
you actually have to build that
india-rubber application or what you can
do is if you're using like a commercial
EMM you can inject settings by a managed
config which will configure each user's
device from an admin console so you
don't actually have to write custom code
to handle the different situations that
make sense Android doctor if everyone
knows there is a concept of a work
profile so if your enterprise or company
supports bringing your own device to
work you can install a work profile
which is a separate container on the
device that allows you to basically
separate your work and personal life
it's it maintains privacy and it'll
actually allows you to now you can turn
it off at night if you
want to to not be getting pings and
working emails and everything like that
all the time and then on the corporate
side if your company actually hands you
a phone or device this device has a lot
more features that you can get pull logs
as deep inspection and it has full admin
visibility on everything that's going on
on it so in these kinds of cases you
know with a lot more enterprises are
using you they use both but for some of
the really specific use cases we're
talking about with especially custom
hardware you probably have a company on
device so here's here's some information
on we don't to go through all these
things but if you're building for work
profile your application automatically
kind of has to handle a few situations
and scenarios and this is important
because you know it's it allows you to
run your app in a limited privileged
container which it might not necessarily
be aware of so a few things here not
really gonna go over them in super
detail but your app might not act like
it usually does there's gonna be
features like the camera might not exist
you might not be able to share things
you might not be able to save files like
you don't really do and you and you
can't handle notifications in the same
way they work a little bit differently
in the word profile so I mentioned badge
configurations earlier just to kind of
go through with that flow looks like
when you're building Android application
you're going to define like how it's
configurable so let's say I'm a email
client well you're probably gonna have
an email address server and depending on
that server type you might have port and
a bunch of other information so you
generated a little XML file which
defines hey I'm expecting an email
address is just a string I'm expecting a
port which is an int and maybe you know
an address which is a string as well and
what that does is play automatically
knows and reads that so that gets
ejected into Google Play which talks to
an EMM which says okay this app has
these settings to configure so when
they're adding from the EMM perspective
or your admin is adding a new phone or
device they would be able to set those
fields automatically so you just start
your phone up and oh look I know this is
John this is email address this is this
so I open the app and it just works
already I don't have to I don't have to
go like try to figure out my email
settings are for example
and then yeah so that's the native side
of things we do have more resources a
couple things I didn't mention from a
design perspective and I mentioned that
there's you know all the different
browsers and the challenges there
obviously also there's a lot of
different Android devices a lot
different Android versions we launched
jetpack two years ago at Google i/o
which is a more holistic support library
for Android and that allows you to more
easily handle backward compatibility
yeah so I think that's it I think we can
I'll pass it back to Sean and then we'll
open it up for questions so so hopefully
this gives you a high-level overview of
building for enterprise I think what we
often coach folks on and John brought
this up at the beginning of the
presentation like this is not a
religious war at the end of the day what
you're building for it needs to depend
on the projects that you're actually
building inside of your organization
there are lots of cases where building
for the web is a really simple way to
get basic work flows into the hands of
your users it's certainly from a brand
at a b2c perspective an absolutely
critical way to be engaging with your
customers but it's not necessarily the
right technology depending on what types
of workflows you're building out I'm for
your enterprise so as John mentioned we
have a ton of tools out there whether
you're building trying to understand how
to build out enterprise apps use some of
the tools that John I mentioned
definitely encourage you to go to those
[Music]